today we're talking about address
validation optimizing gke and no cost
training I'm Stephanie and welcome to
this week in Cloud where we serve you
the lowest latency news
addresses are necessary to help find
people and places deliver goods and even
open bank accounts but typos or
misspellings can be really difficult to
spot addresses that aren't correct and
formatted to local standards can lead to
poor user experiences fail deliveries
and costly customer support and that's
why we are announcing the general
availability release of address
validation it's a new API that can help
improve user experiences by removing
friction at account sign up or checkout
and it can save you time and money for
your business by helping reduce the
impact of invalid addresses on your
operations
cost and optimization are top concerns
when it comes to cloud and according to
our internal research up to one in ten
clusters across the gke fleet is idle at
any given time furthermore among
over-provision workloads 40 of them have
provisioned 30 times the resources they
actually use and 11 of workloads have
provisioned over a hundred times the
needed resources
thankfully there are many best practices
for reclaiming this wasted capacity many
of which we have built directly into gke
so check out the blog for four low
effort High reward ways to reclaim
resources optimize your gke spend
minimize management overhead and reduce
your carbon footprint Cloud technology
has experienced accelerated adoption in
recent years with continued growth
expected into 2023 this means that the
need for organizations to attract and
retain professionals with Cloud skills
continues to grow in parallel and we do
have some great news for the rest of
2022 and in partnership with Google
Cloud Coursera is offering no cost
access to some of our most popular cloud
training to help you hone your skills
and stand out in the job market
so whether you are looking to enhance
your technical competencies Advance your
career acquire more hands-on experience
or earn learning credentials to validate
your knowledge we have the resources
available
if you want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list then
check out the link have any thoughts or
ideas leave us a comment or tweet us
we'll see you in the cloud